Hurry up
this
ah tan tan 8 ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
I'm a
former company slaughterer salaried man world man
It's a store sign habit
[Music] It's
about time to leave drugs outside the territory
[Music]
Hmm Ira-san, please do this
Everyone's wind flows Ghosts living in this house With the
shopkeeper and secretary
[Music]
Hmmm, electricity is good today too  Drag the good times and improve today too
Let's all do our best today too, let's do our best in a relaxed operation
ni
fog story
me
ana
I've decided on a shop Yes this is ah ah
me
[music]
ni
ani
me
ni
aname
ani
today
anuhea
cani
[music] If the
rain leaks I'll call you again Even at my
author's shop  Let me sell
this parallel potion Fierce Potion
It seems like you gave it a name on your own.It's
officially an energy potion, but it
's a potion
that has the effect of recovering from fatigue and awakening.  The performance is furiously sweet potion It's the
first time I've ever had a sweet potion It's a royal welcome
Until now, there were only potions that taste like garbage around here
Well, that's hard work, is
n't it?  Because it's this street, it's a good
position to sell to
a rural grocery
store like ours.  For the
time being, maybe 20 or 25?
Thank you, Regi-kun, that was
great.
50,000 people bought it.
Sister, I think we made it a little too cheap.
It's fine, but it
's okay
Reiji-san's potions will definitely sell
3 units a day for the main potion g Thank you
so much It might be the first time
I
've been praised like this before
Rumors spread with furious momentum in the town of karuta
Po The house in the village with an unreasonable ending is a white rose
B Sen gay Well, I have myself A shocking decision Day
after day, Alf-san's general store is flooded with customers looking for potions
Hurry up everyone  Line up, line up, up
to one per person.
I'm so tired I'm home.
Masu hey Matsui's color failure will be used as an exception
[music]
Bad color
Always here I saved Ella's life So Ella I've been
here all the time Main
railroad Let's go home
Thank you for waiting,
I'm fluffy again.
Thank you for your
patience, Reiji-san, thank you for your hard work.
It's for
Pooh Yes Page 3 later
Can I do
some shopping for you?
Where are you going?
Well, at times like this, Noela moves on instinct
.
What the hell is this Heat One-Two
8 Buy me one?
+ It looks like I made a mistake
Poo San Hmm
[Music] It
's an error in the authority of battle It's
really good Besides ahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
If you say yes, you're right on the street,
and don't
run away Mach,
you
know
, I
'm a geisha.
Who is the alchemist?
I wrote it properly and it's black like that
Ramen toranoana
Eh, can I ask you to explain the situation
?  Well,
Ferris is a very anxious day
.  Mon
nan
na na na
Even if I just bumped into a woman on the street
Oh oh oh I'm sorry We have
a favorite taste,
right?
Do you want to
hear the story of when?
I'm a pharmacist, so I'm a pharmacist, so that kind of
thing helps Faith.  Jet lag
Reiji, what do you think?
Looking at this state, I feel like you're a normal girl, aren't you
?  Go Ferris is your girlfriend,
right
?  This is probably wrong
ah ah ah
Error
What is this written on woolen pants
[Music]
Um, where was that?
[music]
[applause]
um [music] I've been given an example So this is medicine and it's a drink rather than medicine I see, if I can extend this, I
can pay for something bad that's haunting Feiris.
I'll get back to you right away and
stretch it out to her Thank you.
4th 4 It's a
tough time, isn't it?
Ferris
Sogo went right away when he
got offended and steamed.  Wolverines of time After all, you used that medicine to expel your demons, I understand.
No, you don't understand at all
.  A book that makes you feel anxious and irritated.
Mr. Ferris said that he couldn't sleep at night, so I searched for something that would help him sleep and have a healing effect
.
There are things that can
happen, so if I sent it, it wouldn't have been a bear.
I'm a son with a son Come on, I
only have a lot of money
I said I got it
Cheska money I'll see you again
[music]
me
we are t
Everyone has
anxiety about training
erune
ree
[music]
lord mn
j no way it's
me Saijo 5 fender good flow
only the real ones can feel the thin leaf fair flowers that give off an
unpleasant odor I
see,
I'm human so I can't feel it
A good pungent odor may come to your eyes.
Then
[music]
pa
4-
sitters refer to 100% botanical ingredients
[music] last minute error [music]
aname
tana
Page There is no doubt that this will sell well If you
go that far, just like
everyone else said, the botanical deodorant liquid is a big hit as a deodorant for toilets
.
I wonder if I'll try the
potion
yeah
[music]
[applause]
Dragging the fog Thank you for coming to our store today.
me
okay okay
yeah
none Hold
it up and stand  Tamana
town
[music]
i can
netori
[music]
nan
ran ere
ni
's fanboy running ni
eh, even before the tteto every day, ani yeah yeah yeah, even if it's been a while, it's
okay to worry
hahahaha yhea amaran
amaran Let's
go
in ah
[music]
dje annie me